there are very few sort of um you know
magic spells that you cast that um make
a make a complex and difficult problem
go away now to the televised mental
institution over over at MSNBC they
brought on Rachel mattow Rachel mattow
who has been wrong about everything
whether it was Trump impeachment and uh
Russia collusion and covid all of the
big stuff if you pick a big issue Rachel
mat has been wrong about it well listen
to her uh brilliant political analysis
of what just happened I mean listen I I
think in the in the broad Strokes in
terms of our democracy there are very
few magic wands there are there are very
few sort of um you know magic spells
that you cast that um make a make a
complex and difficult problem go away
that just it just doesn't happen very
often in our political system and I
think that we shouldn't be under any
Illusions um about the the character and
the partisan inclinations among other
things of of this current Supreme Court
as it is
constituted that said it is not that is
this is not a crazy thing for a
democracy to do this is um this is this
is something that was a Hallmark of
postwar Germany after World War II this
is something that happened to Jer
bolsonaro in Brazil quite recently this
is something that our own Congress did
in 1868 after our own Civil War
specifically to preclude anybody from
holding office in this country who had
engaged an Insurrection against country
and so it's it's not unheard of but it's
it would it would be an incredible Wild
Card ah well it sounds like she got the
magic wand or the magic potion that she
wants at least temporarily I don't think
she's going to get it longterm we shall
see she has a pretty bad track record of
uh getting things right so we'll see on
that um the idea though that the Supreme
Court is partisan you know it's so
interesting because the Supreme Court
right now generally because of the
makeup of the Court does lean more
conservative but that doesn't mean it's
partisan these people tell you what
their Judicial philosophy is right they
go through the entire process of getting
nominated and they have their hearings
in front of the Supreme Court they get
nominated and then often they go the
other way right John Roberts people
thought he was going to be the allstar
for conservatives and he's in many ways
been a little more on the liberal side
or at least a little more in the middle
so she's only saying the Supreme Court
is partisan because she thinks that the
Supreme Court is not going to do what
she wants it's interesting she doesn't
mention whether she thinks that the
Colorado Court that did this is partisan
they did what she wanted so she's not
going to reference whether they're
partisan at
all